resident Biden falling hard in the polls
and his campaign is off to a rocky start
if only there was some kind of visual
metaphor
[Music]
[Applause]
told him not to chew gum
but don't worry the big guy is okay the
White House says Biden got sabotaged by
a sandbag at the Air Force Academy
graduation today but the president has
bigger problems to deal with like his
non-existent campaign strategy
Mr President how's the re-election
campaign going but you haven't seen me
on the campaign Trail yet
an official campaign rally
Biden is also avoiding debate stages and
it's breaking the heart of that guy from
Dawson's Creek actor James Van Der Beek
yes that Van Der Beek going viral with
his criticism of Biden ducking the
competition
I cannot get over the fact that the
Democratic National Committee
saying there will not be a debate
to decide the nominee for president
are you kidding me over an 80 year old
man
who if he lives will be the oldest
sitting president in the history of the
country
and if he doesn't live as a vice
president whose approval rating is worse
than his this guy is obviously declining
mental faculties I loved him in Breaking
Bad and here's why Biden should get out
there more his White House stunned to
learn that a majority of Americans think
he's corrupt
what do you say to the majority of
Americans who believe that the president
is himself corrupt
can I take that question president the
president the president spoken to this
all right Jesse we're gonna just devote
an entire segment to uh James Van Der
saluth
beak but I want to I want to talk to you
about the fall what do you make of the
Fall what do you think James Vander Beek
thinks of the Fall
the first fall up the stairs of Air
Force One was funny
because there was three Falls in one
right and you it's hard to fall upstairs
and then the bike fall was also funny
yeah get a helmet and he kind of tipped
over this fall was not funny
I wanted it to be funny
when someone sent it to me I looked at
my phone and I expected to laugh yeah
and then I actually felt bad I it's hard
to believe felt bad I know am I maturing
no am I growing a heart yeah what's
wrong with me you're just telling a lie
on National Television you didn't feel
bad I do feel I actually felt bad for
Joe Biden because he's a jerk but he's
also not physically fit enough to be the
president he could have hit his head in
Kamal it could have been president
that's scary we're now with that
territory where this is the third major
fall in two years and he's got two more
years to go and he's asking for another
four right
we're now in the danger zone physically
and we already know that people don't
think he's mentally sharp enough people
think he's too corrupt to be president
so you're going to contrast this with
Trump who's golfing and Biden's falling
with DeSantis campaigning vigorously all
over the country and Joe Biden not
campaigning you have to show effort to
get votes you have to go out there and
ask for votes to campaign for votes
that's what all presidents have done
ever so he's not doing that he's not
going to campaign and I never thought
I'd be saying this but James Van Der
Beek has a point if you're a Democratic
primary voter and you have the oldest
president of all time
and he's fallen and he can't get up
you're going to want to see if he has
what it takes on a stage with an RFK or
a Marianne I know she's your good friend
Greg he said he could be wrong he said I
could be wrong Joe Biden could prove me
wrong he could have the chops but to
deny the opportunity of the country and
the Democratic party to make that
decision feels undemocratic now we were
told how important democracy was
democracy democracy all the last two
years how important democracy was
well the president's not debating not
campaigning and he's going to arrest his
opponent
and then the White House Press Secretary
can't answer any questions about it is
that Democratic that's not very
Democratic to me well well done Kennedy
uh James Van Der Beek might have been as
big as you in the 1990s could he be 155
Greg yes yes but he does have a giant
head one of the biggest heads in in I
guess the entertainment industry could
that head save democracy well when
you've lost Vander Beek you've lost a
Big Slice of America and I think we all
know that and we need to recognize that
also he had a massive forehead when he
was on Dawson's Creek and in Varsity
Blues and I think the the wrinkles have
really helped him yes uh he's he he's
sassy and sexy all at the same time and
yes I think the President should be
challenged because that's actually how
Joe Biden turned things around during
the 2020 debates is you know he had a
bunch of wet mops on stage and they
tried to come at him bro and it was not
successful also like that debate stage
should have been where Kamala Harris's
political career ended I still don't
know like to your point no one wants to
to see an older person fall no one wants
to see someone get hurt especially the
president of the United States with his
bony concussed finger on the nuclear
button but you're right it's because
we're all terrified of a Harris
presidency so you know if if James
Vander Beek is going to pay us the
compliment of being blunt then why can't
we do the same thing and ask why can't
we swap in another vice presidential
candidate that is true that is true Dana
um were you struck by the words of James
Van Der Beek
well
it's Tori Spelling oh that was maybe
Marcia Cross oh I like that yeah
remember Melrose Place yeah yeah
um so
in 2015 Hillary Clinton would Dodge
debates from Bernie Sanders but they
actually had a primary that was an open
seat okay so the both the Republican
party and the Democratic party have
basically shut down any sort of primary
or debate when they have a incumbent
president that wants to run for
reelection Joe Biden wanted to stay
looking presidential as long as possible
but some things were happening people
were getting restless and they weren't
sure if he was actually going to run
remember all those rumors for so long
that he's definitely not going to run
he's definitely not going to run and
then they kept saying remember he hinted
all along he's like I got something to
tell you soon they got pushed into doing
it sooner because people are concerned
about his age when I say people I mean
Democrats almost 70 percent of Democrats
are concerned about his age which means
that probably 90 percent are concerned
about it and that means that every day
Republicans should be on the campaign
Trail saying if Joe Biden wins this
election every single day will be
possibly kamala's inauguration day and
try to run with that because he if he
doesn't want to debate RFK Junior and I
understand he probably won't and I
understand following the historic
precedent on that that doesn't bother me
that much
you know Jessica just imagine
hypothetically if the nuclear button was
in front of Joe Biden when he fell he
would have fallen and pressed on it and
the world would be over are you happy
now that you voted for him I'm trying to
voted for the the extinction of America
and the world the world yes
do you definitely stand when you hit the
button right because you could do it
sitting and then there would be low risk
of there being any problems
um thank you Dana for explaining the
precedent there with the debates so I
don't have to do that part I'd like to
talk about RFK Jr a little bit and I
mentioned this last week I have not met
a single Democrat who was interested in
RFK Jr I've met a lot of conservatives
that are hanging on his every word and
talking about how this is a guy that
gets it not one Democrat I'm talking
about normal Democrats you might meet
Politico types people who have supported
other candidates Like Bernie Sanders's
people who don't like Biden who didn't
like Hillary aren't even saying like RFK
is the dream Bernie's already said he's
going to come out and support Biden now
what does that mean that his support and
Marianne Williamson's which is about 10
right now is people who are concerned
about another four years of this but
there was a really interesting focus
group uh they wrote about it yesterday
in the New York Times run by a Christian
soul to Sanderson a republican pollster
talked to 11 disinfect affected
Democrats who all have big concerns
about Biden not a single one said that
they would vote for Trump or DeSantis
over him so that's still a huge mountain
to climb for them in terms of the
corruption point you know and I
understand it was funny to hear Korean
Jean-Pierre say Jesus really you know
audibly and Kirby's reaction but this is
something that a they're going to have
to deal with and continue to push back
on but now there is so much fodder to be
discussing what's going on on the other
side we we know from yesterday there's
audio of President Trump talking about
how he had a classified document about a
potential attack on Iran in his
possession at Bedminster where I I don't
think you do any of your presidential
work necessarily that's with Jack Smith
now people are saying that it's going to
be obstruction now and Espionage if he
ends up
what you think it's a joke it's not a
joke the national Records Office reached
out to Trump's lawyers on May 6 in 2021
and said you have documents that we own
send them back three days later we have
images of trump boarding a plane for
Bedminster and boxes being carted okay
so you can you can send the Iranians
billions in cash in the middle of the
night but you can't have a document
Jesse Waters he can always go lower real
quick before we go I just want to know
what went through your mind when you saw
the fall
I was scared for him like I would be
scared for anyone I was happy to know
that at least there was a sandbag that
he tripped over but anyone who falls
like that oh you believe the sandbag
thing I believe
okay you know what we have a president
who can't walk we have one in a
wheelchair before what do you care I
want you can do the job I'm gonna wait
to see what James vanderbeek has to say
about the sandbag right yeah because
Hollywood's coming for the Democratic
party with that one I think we're being
sandbagged on the sandbag right yep I
think I should exit this segment on that
note that's what they're telling us yes
before Jesse goes lower I wonder Brian
Kilmeade I want you to do me a favor I
want you to click to subscribe to the
Fox News YouTube page this is the only
way that I know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on Fox you can get it
all here on YouTube so subscribe right
now